[Music]
you guys shoot Pretty Little Liars here
right across from you right by over near
the bay right there right right in there
in that area I see you a lot and how am
I looking when you see me yeah I'm Tasik
really yeah and you gave me you give me
like little waves here and there and I'm
like oh Conan just way to me high and
then I just drive past and then you see
me chasing you can you see me yeah it's
creepy when I do that I've been asked to
stop you guys 70 we talked about this
backstage briefly but you have a all the
different casts have a little golf cards
they drive in and you guys have a souped
up sort of pink one that says Pretty
Little Liars I know we just have a
regular golf cart that we stole from a
golf course
no yeah we have this awesome hot pink
golf cart and has like alligator seats
and it's really awesome it was the cat's
idea we were like okay season three we
have to have an awesome golf cart
right we're doing well hot pink it's
worth doing better than you apparently
cuz we got a hot pink golf cart so you
have to work on that what are you
talking about you know I chose to steal
ours from a golf course I wanted to take
those stuffed shirts down a peg huh
you tell me on the printer with your I
know we have one that's street-legal we
have a street legal golf cart we can
take cars on the freeway if we want to
try and take mine on the freeway and see
how long I've had people see me in our
golf cart on the 405 freeway going 85
miles an hour just crying my eyes out
you began acting as a kid you started
very young yeah I started around 8 9 8
or 9 I was doing commercials and I
worked as an extra a lot but then I'm
from Orange County so I would I would
drive here with my mom and we always go
to Bob's Big Boy and I would see Drew
Carey there every morning for breakfast
so out of the same Bob's Big Boy
every morning yeah okay so I went up to
him and I was like hi I didn't really
know like who he was but like I knew his
name my mom's like that's true Carey and
I was like okay cool
so I would have to or I could have your
autograph and he autographed my headshot
and I was like I want to be an actor and
he's like well good luck to you so I
went on my audition and I booked it I
was like oh my gosh he's about like a
charm so then I would always go to Bob
good boy I'd see drew Carey and get his
autograph again I'd go to my audition
and I would book it so I just thought
that uh you know you saying this is
gonna be drew carey's gonna be mobbed
now aspiring actresses then hunt down
wherever he is now one of your first
jobs was on a soap what soap were you on
Days of Our Lives
Days of Our Lives yeah and I would
imagine like you were pretty young when
you were on days of early I was yes as
opposed to now yeah my old self exactly
how when you're on Days of Our Lives you
had romantic scenes I did have did you
have your first kiss ever yeah on
television yeah it's gotta be strange it
was very strange
maile I mean I didn't you know I got on
TV but it was later in my life four
months after my first kiss at 30
myself but so what what happened here
they had to you had to do this on
television in front of everyone
yes I got on set I had my cousin driving
me that day I didn't want my mom there I
was really nervous so uh the the guy is
playing my boyfriend he was in his
mid-20s and I was 15 at the time and I
was like hey so just you know this is my
first kiss he's like Oh mine too
don't worry I was like no no no this is
my first my real kiss as a human being
yes so um just throw that out there
don't do anything weird and and it
wasn't a party scene so there was like
all these extras there and then you have
like the whole crew and manured and and
the producers were like okay so tilt
your head this way and then go this way
it's also technical right kiss on screen
so that just made it even more awkward
but I'm yeah it was very interesting a
very interesting first kiss right least
you have it documented that's I do and
that money does do them I have a look I
look back watching I was like wow that's
very awkward looking but oh wow looks
like you had no idea what you were doing
I had no idea you know who's a great
kisser drew Carey
I'm just so not awkward now he's gonna
be mobbed by everyone else